vous avez rencontré quand christian vous
l'avez rencontrée ça fait trois ans
trois ans à wade oui et
nous étions amis sur facebook d'accord
après il m'a proposé de venir de faire
un stage si en france et c'était comme
ça l'occasion et vous venez vous venez
d'où en fait tellement je suis marocaine
d'accord l'album on embrasse tous les
marocains qui nous regarde voilà qu'on
aime voila
voila et
mais vous avez eu un volet il existe un
amour de mecs exactement j'avais eu un
coup de coeur exactement vous le
connaissiez ou pas du tout connaissiez
les frères bogdanoff vous pas du tout
bien sûr pas bien sûr tout le monde les
connaît de nice ça qu'ils font et vous
est il blessé mais bien voilà c'est oui
on a vécu des ddd bons moments ensemble
et
[Musique]
c'était quelqu'un de très gentil
le jour où je suis venu ici en france
ils m'ont accueilli à l'aéroport et les
gens les personnes comme ça ils prennent
des photos avec lui s'étaient jetés dans
un autre monde vient de voir son frère
ou pas du tout
ça fait pas lanto c'était
ça fait six mois que j'ai fait
connaissance avec i cor vous n'avez pas
longtemps on va tout à fait mais je vois
là alors
en décembre dernier donc les deux frères
ont contracté le qu'ovide il vous
parlait parfois du virus d'amiens où
china oui oui nous en parler évidemment
il n'était pas déjà n'était pas anti
vaccins j'ai toujours entendu pareille
s'affolera des gens qu'ils étaient en
tirer que c'est pas du tout cas moi ils
m'ont encouragé m vacciner 1 vacciner
mes parents donc il y avait pas de
difficultés là dessus il faisait plutôt
attention au geste barrière ils
portaient le masque ça fait des mois et
des mois qu'on ne faisait plus la bise
donc il était conscient de ce qui se
passait sauf qu'ils ne se sentaient pas
concernés y penser qu'ils étaient
suffisamment fort suffisamment robuste
pour ne pas être attaqué par ce virus
mais il était totalement conscient de ce
qui se passait dans ce monde et je
voudrais juste de remercier cyril parce
que tu as été extrêmement bienveillant
valérie également a fait une très belle
émission par hasard vous les adorez
shocker bref partie de la famille unie
et il ya plein de gens qui ont parlé qui
ont raconté ce qu'ils n'ont pas vécu
nous on est pris le temps de le faire on
a voulu se recueillir penser à a
à consoler notre coeur notre âme parce
que c'était pas évident et aujourd'hui
c'est le moment de parler et je te
remercie mais c'est moi c'est moi qui
travaillais compréhensif et tous tes sms
nous on fait vraiment chaud à moi je
vous dis mais je vois là il me manque
vraiment voilà ces deux personnages que
j'adorais pas moi je les aimais vraiment
cessé ce que vous lister les invités que
je préférais voilà il s'était vraiment
immo imorou coup je les aime beaucoup
mais d'ailleurs je le dis toujours je
les aime parce que je parle encore au
présent de allant au départ des escales
avec des petits symptôme n'est pas donc
aucune inquiétude tout à fait puisqu'il
a même il a donné une interview quelques
heures avant d'être testés positifs il
allait bien il n'y avait pas de
difficultés
il a commencé à être fatigués vers le 5
5 décembre cinq ans là vers le 5
décembre et c'est là que il a commencé à
être vraiment fatigué mais il n'était
pas inquiet il ne pensait pas que ça
allait être si grave je pensais pas que
ça allait être dramatiques ici il se
soigner avec des vitamines
des clémentines très important
maintenant de mes clients at il aussi
celle qui avait poussé grichka aller à
l'hôpital clics seulement pourquoi vous
aviez vous étiez vous étiez un moment là
il faut y aller ça ça exactement avait
vu mal oui non je déjà jeu j'étais chez
moi et
on envoie des messages en parle sur
what's app et tout ça mais
après j'ai vu que par exemple mais il ne
répond pas vite quand je l'appelle il me
répondait pas et j'étais très inquiète
après je suis allé chez lui et j'ai
rester devant la porte presque deux
heures parce que j'étais très inquiète
je voulais pas taper sur la porte je me
suis dit là il dort dès que je vais
entendre un peu de bruit je vais je vais
l'appeler pour qu'il m'ouvre la porte
quelques jours donc heureusement c'était
c'était le cas c'était le cas et quand
il m'a
ouvrait la porte
je les trouvais qu'il était très très
fatiguée et mais je lui dis c'est
indispensable d'aller à l'hôpital et
voilà il m'a dit d'accord et au début
c'était un peu difficile pour lui parce
que il est contre l'idée d'aller à
l'hôpital c'était quelqu'un c'était très
bien dans sa santé dans la peau et tout
ça donc
après j'ai pris la décision sans me dire
oui ou non j'ai appelé le samu et on
attendait je pense 20 minutes comme ça
et c'était c'était à 2 heures du matin
oui c'était à 2 heures du matin et voilà
et quant aux ragots en gage qu'ils
étaient ensemble à ce moment là non non
non du tout donc tous les deux ils ont
eut ils ont contracté à malices assez ça
s'est empiré en même temps on fait payer
un petit décalage l'accord est tombé
malade quelques jours après mais grichka
lui était convaincu hurlant que ça
allait passer moi j'ai re il m'a envoyé
un texto le 18 donc la veille d'être un
tube et où il me dit c'est une mascarade
demain je sors tout va bien donc
jusqu'au bout il y as cru il y avait ils
avaient mais comme cela une sorte de
phobie de l'hôpital phobie des
médicaments il ne prenait même pas un
doliprane ils sont toujours soignées de
façon avec des avec des plantes des
huiles essentielles dont qu'ils étaient
en fait grichka en tout cas puisque
c'est de lui dont j'étais plus proche
s'est sentie prisonnier de la situation
réellement il ne se sentait pas à sa
place il ne comprenait pas ce qu'il
faisait à l'hôpital alors d'accord
ils ont donc aux russes ils ont ils ont
réussi à se parler une fois à l'hôpital
ou pas du tout une permanence permanent
ferme a non seulement ils étaient à deux
trois chambres d'écart ils avaient leurs
téléphones portables ils se sont mis
dans un bon coeur c'est-à-dire qu'il ne
répondra plus personne c'est pour ça
qu'on devait y aller sinon on n'avait
aucune nouvelle et il s'appelait d'une
chambre d'hote pour savoir s'il avait
mangé quel était le taux de saturation
qu'avaient dit les médecins jusqu'au
bout en fait là ses soucis et de l'autre
plus que de lui même à chaque fois ça a
toujours été ça alors malheureusement le
28 décembre riesch qu'est ce qui va nous
quitter des suites de la maladie
on sait qu'ils gore il a il n'a pas su
grave car était parti
non du tout du tout parce qu'ils étaient
il était dans le dans un
il était lui aussi un tube est donc dans
le coma il ne l'a pas su après il ne l'a
pas su de façon verbale parce qu'il
n'était pas en état de ce qu'on lui dise
et vous pensez qu'il a écrit je pense
que le lien qui avait entre eux ils ont
étaient jumeaux
infiniment c'est à dire que je pense
qu'il ya un lien on ne peut pas
comprendre la gémellité quand on n'est
pas jumeaux alors hier il y avait un
documentaire sur sur bfm qui parle de
plein de choses les erreurs
scientifiques des bogdanoff igor qui
introduit c'est son ex amie julie à
l'époque voilà on avait parlé de cette
affaire de moeurs le plagiat de leur
livre il parle de tout ça est ce que est
ce que ça vous a choqué qui parle de
tout ça dans ce documentaire
je sais ce que tu veux dire mais oui le
reportage était incomplet parce que ils
ont parlé que d'aider leurs problèmes
judiciaires mais ils n'ont pas parlé de
leur parcours lors
d'un projet leur projet les livrer tout
ça dans ça vous attriste et ça m'a
embêté qui ne parle pas de l'avenir
parce que
il y avait tant x et tu lui assuré
puisque quiconque qui devait arriver
dans quelques semaines il devait
rencontrer le pape pour la suite de dieu
et la science ils voulaient monter une
plate forme d'accès à des programmes
le scientifique
donc il y avait plein de projets
évidemment je comprends qu après la
ligne éditoriale fait qu'il faut parler
de tous les sujets il n'avait que 45
minutes ils ont eu peu de temps pour
réaliser aussi le documentaire dans
quelques jours il y aura nrj 12 on verra
si c'est mieux ou pas mais globalement
en tout cas j'ai été déçu qu'ils ne
parlent pas davantage des projets et qui
est peut-être un déséquilibre entre igor
et grichka on parlait un peu plus d'igor
que de grichka après si vous lisez
partout c'est igor et grichka là j'étais
un peu la position de grichka tout le
temps ils se mettaient un peu en retrait
c'était sa façon sans doute aussi
d'aimer son frère damien et jaillit il
vous manque fort oui
mais oui c'est bien un sentiment
parce que là je me sens tout seul et à
chaque fois je pense à lui à chaque fois
quand quelqu'un me parle de grichka
toujours j'ai les larmes aux yeux parce
qu'il l'a il a hélas il a laissé un vide
que personne ne peut le remplir et
parce qu'il a fait beaucoup de choses
pour moi il était toujours à côté des
mots de moi et c'est un sentiment
horrible est tellement difficile de
de ne plus voir la personne que tu aimes
que que tu as vécu de très bons moments
ensemble